let's talk about what a good structure  of a cv looks like when i successfully  applied to mckinsey my cv looked like  this it was just the one pager just one  clean page in the header you put your  name your personal address and some  contact details and then only next i  talked about my work experience listing  all the internships that i did and all  the impact that i had there next section  is extracurricular activities here you  talk about all your social and pro bono  work that you conducted in the past as  well as some other relevant leadership  roles that you took on on top of your  regular university studies next include  a section called honors and awards when  you include all your scholarships and  other prizes last but release the  section and other qualifications and  interests where you list all your  language skills other certificates that  you made that are relevant follow me for  more career insights